bonjour aujourd'hui pour notre page
consacrée aux journées du patrimoine je
vous propose de découvrir non pas un
monument mais plutôt une collection
privée
elle n'est ouverte qu occasionnellement
au public et ce week-end elle sera
accessible
alors suivez moi je vous propose de vous
donner un avant goût en exclusivité dans
cet espace plus de 1000 objets liés au
cinéma
pascal rigaud passionné par le septième
art les a collectionnées au fil des
années c'est adolescents après la visite
d'une salle de projection que son amour
est né et ont regardé par ce petit
hublot vous qui donnez dans la salle
évidemment et ça ça me donnait envie
enfin quelque chose que j'avais jamais
ressentez jamais vu et puis là je me
suis mis à aimer quand même le cinéma
donc voir des films
film pellicule caméra ou encore
projecteurs il y en a partout dans sa
maison sur 400 mètres carrés
de quoi en perdre la tête mais pas pour
ce collectionneur il connaît l'histoire
de chacune de ses pièces sur le bout des
doigts
là c'est un appareil
c'est date de 1908 1910 en gros et qu'il
ya une petite histoire parce que cet
appareil la dila travail et un ouvert ça
fonctionnait à la main donc il fallait
absolument mecs font charger son film
est tourné à la marque
chacun de ces objets est ton état de
fonctionner car cet amoureux les a tous
restaurés pour les admirer les visiteurs
viennent parfois de loin
il faut dire que sur ses étagères pascal
rigaud possède quelques trésors comme
cette toute première caméra amateur qui
date des années 1930 à la porte et la
vie de famille à la maison et le cinéma
la maison c'est à dire qu'on peut
essayer de faire des photos eh bien on
pouvait avoir de cinéma chez soi mais de
sa famille on pouvait filmer ses amis on
pouvait fumer ses enfants cet amoureux
possède aussi deux salles de cinéma de
quoi faire pâlir d'envié tous les
passionnés du 7e et c'est ici dans cette
salle de cinéma que je vous retrouve aux
côtés de frédéric rolland l'heure
frédéric rolland vous êtes enseignant
consultant mais surtout collectionneurs
avec votre oncle vous possédez également
dans la nièvre une importante collection
qui sera aussi accessible au public ce
week-end
qu'est ce que le public pourra découvrir
en nous c'est plus une collection de
films une petite cinémathèque locale en
fait avec quand même 2000 unitaire dans
tous les formats du 8 au 35 mm en
passant par le cesc est très courant
dans les collections et donc nous avons
un peu tous des films de fiction des
documentaires et puis une petite
collection d'appareils beaucoup plus
modeste que celle de pascal picq ou mais
néanmoins intéressante avec une
soixantaine d'appareils
alors finalement on se rend compte
beaucoup de collectionneurs aussi
beaucoup de pièces tous ces objets c'est
un véritable patrimoine aussi à
conserver
c'est très paradoxal parce que même si
les conditions chez les collectionneurs
sont pas forcément exceptionnel au
niveau des conditions de conservation
puisqu'il est difficile de faire les
salles climatisées à 3 degrés ce type de
choses néanmoins chez les
collectionneurs on peut trouver des
oeuvres de films institutionnels ou des
films de long métrage ou des courts
métrages qui n'ont pas été préservé par
les grandes institutions parce que à
l'époque de leur sortie
c'était considéré comme des films
secondaire
ce qui fait qu'en fait c'est pas
forcément parce qu'on a des petits
moyens qu'on n'a pas des collections bon
état merci frédéric rolland alors vous
l'aurez compris ce week-end plutôt que
de vous faire une toile je vous propose
de venir découvrir ces passionnantes
collection pour plus d'informations
rendez vous sur notre site
france 3 bourgogne au point fr